come on Anthony had a career I've got
huge cheers and lots of love from the
Knick fans this Portland Trailblazers
blown out how did pounded into
submission
where are the places Vitamix bar is
random Lila kena
hey Robinson all and terrific games
tonight
Robinson tied the knick record for most
field goals made without a Miss in a
single game that was 11 for 11 he had 22
points and 8 rebounds so Viktor Robinson
meanwhile Julius Randle had 22 points
and 13 rebounds as an acute 48 percent
from the field some Jersey swaps here
mix only had 7 turnovers in the game
just 2 of the second half Marcus Morris
who said he powdered his game after
Carmelo Anthony where was always a huge
fan was gonna get his Carmelo Anthony
Jersey Morris after our life blessed her
first half had a great third quarter so
did Melo what's the fans they've
happened tonight they got what they
wanted from hello
the Knicks fans got what
victory
[Applause]
and so many different dicks for taking
and what was the dominant victory
portland team that needed a win but the
Blazers lose their fifth straight
[Applause]
the playoff picture night in the West